draft day edition of pft ot we think the
draft starts with pick number three
because we think
slash sort of know that joe burrow will
be picked number one over all of the
cincinnati bengals and chase young will
be picked number two overall to
washington but chris there is a
possibility slim as it may be it's a
possibility that we can't ignore that
both picks will be traded that it'll
still be borough and young one and two
but reports have emerged over the course
of the past day that
washington
has heard from the falcons the falcons
that would be fascinating about a
possible deal that would allow them to
get chase young and also the dolphins
trying to get into that number one
position to get joe burrow let's start
with burro we talked a little bit about
this during pft live the idea that the
dolphins would like to get up you and i
have known the dolphins love joe burrow
it's not a smoke screen it's real the
question is what does it take to get joe
burrow and you know this possibility and
i don't think it's going to happen now
but yeah as of yesterday there was talk
of the dolphins trying to get the third
overall pick while keeping the fifth
overall pick it made me wonder are they
trying to get those two picks to make it
even more enticing to the bengals to get
it to a point where they can't say no
and they won't say no but to me that's
the great mystery what does it take to
get the bengals to say yes and will they
know
when they should say yes or has their
overall dysfunction caused them to be
unable to recognize that there may be an
offer on the table for joe burrow that
they should not refuse
well yeah i mean i i would think the
bengals have a uh
are smart enough
and at least have some
price that where they would go okay all
right guys let's have a meeting here i
i've been offered you know
three first first-round picks and the
miami dolphins the to we'd have to move
back to five and they get our number one
spot you know i would think there'd have
to be some price that's gonna make them
reconsider it mike what is that price i
mean what is it you know or if you're
the bengals and you're sitting there and
you get you know the the washington
redskins offer that they made to who was
it the rams that year to get up to the
number two pick in the draft
would you do it i ask you
well look
you're talking about now and it's almost
apples to apples because washington went
six to two four spots up they gave up
that sixth pick two more first rounders
and a second rounder and those were
future first rounders the dolphins have
two other first-rounders they could
throw on to the pile i mean if the
dolphins say take all three of our first
rounders plus something more at what
point do the bengals say that's enough
we will take it and that's right i still
i'm not convinced because i the bengals
have such a reputation for being
stubborn right and sometimes it works to
your advantage because if you're dealing
with someone and this is always great
negotiation if you've got somebody who's
very motivated to do a deal and your
attitude is i don't care i don't even
want to do the deal you have to convince
the person to do the deal it's going to
take more than it otherwise would and if
you are determined to get that deal done
the bengals
by virtue of their own i don't want to
say incompetence but just if their
inability to understand what would be a
good trade here or their reluctance to
understand what would be a good trade
they may get more maybe it'll be all
three first-round picks that the
dolphins currently have plus a first
round pick next year who knows
but
yeah if the dolphins are determined to
do it chris they did you just keep
throwing stuff onto the pile up until
the moment that burrow is picked and you
can even do it after borough is picked
just like we saw with eli manning and
philip rivers back in 2004
no i i mean you're right they're all
real possibilities uh you know i think
there's two things that jump out to me
here i mean one i i would not recommend
this for the miami dolphins i i don't
you know build your football team you
know build your football team draft a
quarterback somewhere else here in the
first round and go from there i mean it
doesn't always have to be about one guy
and this guy but i think a lot of it it
would that will be determined at least
in my opinion
would be
of what the bengals think not only of
joe burrow but of justin herbert
with that you know okay like if you have
a peyton manning type grade on joe
burrow right
all right then i would say don't trade
them like if it's like oh my gosh i
don't know if we really ever had a grade
this high on a quarterback since who
know you know whoever that might be you
know some
you know like i said a peyton manning or
just some superstar that we've seen
throughout the nfl if that's the case
then i would say no don't do it at any
cost and just go from there
now
if you have a grade that's still really
good and of course the first pick of the
draft good but you have justin herbert
uh just slightly below him with also an
impressive draft grade then if i'm the
cincinnati band goes i'm thinking about
doing this once i get the trade offer
that i think is is deserved for a guy
like joe burrow uh i would think about
it but i think yeah go ahead but how
much if you're the bengals how much do
you factor into that the possibility
that i i don't know it could drive you
crazy if you think about it enough
because if we do the deal and we get all
these other picks then we have to use
the picks right it's almost more
pressure like it's easier to just say
burrow we won't burrow burrows that
can't miss guy you give us a bunch of
other picks and then hell we got to
figure out what to do with them and
chances are we're going to screw them up
potentially so i if for me i i look i'm
sold on burrow so i would take the
bengals approach and i would say i don't
want to do it i don't want to do it i
don't want to do it and i would hope
like hell the dolphins don't put so much
on the table that i start thinking oh
crap now maybe i should do it
well yeah i you know again
you know i i got stephen ross is one of
those owners where i think he's going to
stick his nose into this situation so i
think it's a real possibility you know
and it's one of the things that i don't
necessarily like that i always hear
uh about
you know
steven ross is that he's always stuck
his nose into certain football matters
and i just don't think that's right here
and i do worry about that for them you
know and i think you know the other
thing i it's a interesting little
factoid here about this conversation too
the bengals didn't
they coached justin herbert in the
senior bowl
so and they came away i know very
impressed by what they saw but i also
know at this point they've been blown
away by joe burrow in the pre-draft
process too so
that's the you know the other
interesting part of this conversation
but i think ultimately you know hey
maybe if you get you get offered four
first round picks you know the swap
being one of them which is really just a
swap okay but then three others added on
to that then i'd probably do it if i'm
the cincinnati bengals
yeah it it really really would just it's
the kind of thing where you know
sometimes we like our lives to be simple
and
and and it's so much easier when you
just know what you're going to do and
you don't have anything that is
distracting you from what it is that you
want to do and then all of a sudden and
here's the best example i can give and
this dates back to when i used to
practice law the easiest cases for me
were the ones where the other side
wasn't offering anything of any real
value and i could focus exclusively on
getting ready for trial and then all of
a sudden they cart they just start
coming around with and then it's like
you know now they're making a real offer
and it's like it makes it difficult like
what do i do door number one door number
two i'd rather not have that dilemma i'd
rather it be so clear and that may be
the problem the dolphins may put just
enough there that it drives the bengals
crazy all day long and and i feel like
it's gonna happen shepherd's report is
the dolphins have been calling and
calling and calling and the bengals have
said we're not gonna trade the pick
nothing prevents the dolphins from
sending the bengals an offer and if it's
big enough
that may that may spark what could
become a real stunner by the time the
day's over and and and look i i at the
risk of alienating bengals fans any more
than we already have in this pre-draft
process
what if burrow really does prefer the
dolphins to the bengals what if he
really does what if that's the hammer
that gets applied at some point what if
the dolphins put enough on the table to
create doubt for the bengals
and then at the right moment when it's
right on the fence
burroughs people provide the push
you know that you know he's going to
hold out you're going to have a tr
you're going to have issues with him
contractually he's going to want this
that or the other thing and he's going
to want a new contract after three years
and he's going to hold out after three
years if he doesn't get his new contract
just something to get them to say screw
it we'll take this offer i feel like
there's a way that the dolphins and
boroughs people can maybe tag team it
definitely yeah yeah the bengals
softened up and get the deal done chris
well no i mean i i agree you're right i
mean if that would do it if you made him
a great trade offer and then got word
from joe burrows camp like hey
he doesn't want to play for you guys i
don't know any other way to say he's
going to play hardball with you guys if
you draft him
that would certainly change things and
then you're you're kind of cornered
there if you're the cincinnati bengals
and i think you do make that trade uh
but you know i don't know maybe you
don't make that trade if you feel like
you know if you got such a lower grade
on the next quarterback on your board
that you don't even feel comfortable
with the other quarterbacks i don't know
what they would do in that scenario but
i doubt that's the case but this is
going to be one of the fascinating
things miami's fascinating in this strat
because of the joe burrow factor will
they just sit there at number five and
take justin herbert will they maybe you
know wait to the teens and see if
tuataga biola is still there and then
make a play for him there you know there
there's just so many different scenarios
right now and i think that's what makes
uh tonight's viewing awesome as far as
the nfl drafts concern
and jake laser who i believe was the
first one to report that the falcons
were going to try to trade up for a
receiver in 2011. glazer's plugged in
with the falcons glazer's plugged in
with thomas de mitroff and i think
dimitrov's approach when he wants to
trade up is to get it out there so
people know so people are aware so maybe
you start getting phone calls back from
teams that would like to trade down
because now we know there's someone out
there who wants to trade up all the way
to number two would not be easy
washington i think would have to be
blown away to give up the opportunity to
get chase young but it just shows you
that hey maybe it'll be somebody else
who knows maybe this is washington's
chance to turn the tables eight years
after they moved up to get number two
maybe they moved down from number two
and uh and get a big haul but it's the
same concern you're giving up a guy
who's a sure thing and you're getting
more lottery tickets but there's no
guarantee you're going to turn those
into productive players for the same
reasons the bengals may not want to have
to even worry about figuring out what
the right thing to do is if i'm
washington i kind of don't want to get
blown away either i'd rather have chase
young think back to last year would the
cardinals rather have kyle murray or
what someone would have traded for them
for kylo murray would the 49ers rather
have nick bosa or what someone would
have traded them for nick bosa i think
both teams would say we're glad we did
what we did
yeah that's a great example mike i mean
that's a great point by you you're right
and i mean you know with the with the
falcons city sitting at what
are they at 16 or at 17 i can't remember
exactly but they're at 16 all right
i mean that would take some trade some
haul of players and people and assets to
get up to number two i mean really i
can't even think in like modern history
if we've seen a team make that type of
jump have we into the top one or two
picks from number 16
i mean that would be like unforeseen
areas there and you know again the i
just the falcons they're a team that
we've seen where i want to go what you
need depth on your team elena you guys
for the second year in a row had like
three injuries and the team fell apart
so i would be scared of that if i'm then
chase young is special we know that
uh but i would also say there's another
pass rusher in this draft kayla von
chason who i think is special as well
and
he'll probably be in that right around
that 15 16 17
maybe somewhere a little earlier maybe
they make a play for him but the falcons
i understand them they run that san
francisco seattle scheme right they saw
what it did for the the 49ers last year
whoa to have that type of defense
aligned it can change your team it
becomes a force throughout the nfl and i
think they're probably looking at it the
same way but man that's just too far to
go up even for a guy like chase young
who's that talented i can't even imagine
what that would take to move up 14 spots
uh to get the number two pick which even
has great value greater value than just
trading up 14 spots from the end of the
round to the middle of the round
chris it was four years ago that the
then st louis rams moved up from number
15 to number one to actually it was
their first year in la to get jared goff
that's the lowest a team had ever been
to moving okay number one so it was 15
to 1. so 16 to 2 same number of spots if
they could find a way to pull it off
what the rams gave up
for that for that uh
uh draft and it was one of those
complicated deals with a lot of other
stuff here's the terms the rams got the
first overall pick in 2016 from the
titans a fourth round pick from the
titans in 2016 and a sixth round pick in
2016 from the titans they gave up first
rounder in 2016 two second rounders in
2016 third rounder in 2016
first rounder in 2017 and another
third-rounder in 2017. that doesn't
strike me
as a massive haul not huge for the
titans
right so
hey if if the i'm telling you if the
dolphins say to the bengals we'll give
you all three of our first round picks
and the bengals say no
wow
or or we'll give you how about this
we'll give you all three of our first
round picks this year and next year's
first round pick if you're the bengals
should you take that yeah i would take
that i would i mean yes that's you know
three extra first round picks and you're
gonna fall down four spots and still be
able to get a quarterback there at
number five that i think is very
talented so i would take that and you
know to your point with the rams moving
up to number one and making that trade
with the tennessee titans
you know i think this will take more
than that for jerry first off that was
you know jared goff you know which i
know some teams in football did not view
as anything near the top pick in
football right so
chase young there is no argument here
this is a once every four or five years
type of player and i think it'll take
more to come up and get him because yeah
he's miles guarantees julius peppers i
mean this has a chance to be a hall of
fame game changer for your organization
and i think it will take more of a draft
hall to get chase young than it uh you
know falcons the redskins than it did
for the rams to trade up with the titans
to get jared goff i still can't believe
i mean man the rams traded all that away
to get jared goff holy crap
i think the one thing
that that will
cause a team to think about giving up
the bird in the hand and taking all
those draft picks there's that arrogance
that you have to have that confidence
you have to have to be a good evaluator
you think that you can turn those picks
into potential hall of fame players so
yeah i know this one guy's a sure thing
but i'm certain in my abilities that i'm
going to use those picks on players that
are going to become great players even
if history is going to tell us before
too long that they screwed it all up
before those lottery tickets are
scratched off they have so much more
value chris and i think that lure of
having the opportunity to have one of
those historic drafts the steelers in 74
the ravens in 96 when they got ray lewis
and jonathan ogden the same year the
bucks in 95 when they got derek brooks
and warren sapp in the same draft that
lure of taking the one potential hall of
famer and getting two or more that could
be the thing that gets the bengals or
washington to do it
yeah no i i agree agree then you know
yes it's gonna be a little bit about
you're right how these gms and
organizations see the draft and do they
feel that they're going to get you know
players that they need
and uh be able to strike players that
are you know difference makers for your
organization like you're saying
all right well that's it for pftot we'll
be back tomorrow with another edition of
pft live reacting to everything that
happens tonight check out our social
media pages tonight for real-time
reaction i'll be doing some videos that
are turning up somewhere i don't know
wherever i got the video set up down in
the barn we're gonna hang out down there
we're gonna have a good time and we're
gonna enjoy the draft the closest thing
to a sporting event that we've had since
march 11 and it may be the closest thing
chris to a sporting event that we have
for a long time enjoy the draft buddy
we'll be in touch all day long everybody
check us out at profootballtalk.com
we'll see you friday
see ya
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports